miso poached salmon with Asian
vegetables
organization is key in the kitchen take
a couple of minutes before you start and
set yourself up make sure you know where
everything is stock spatula pan Etc it
becomes less stressful but more
importantly the end results are
incredible
[Music]
first off
panel
with
and stock
with this amazing fermented soybean
puree into the pan three nice
tablespoons gas on now get your fish
stock and whisk into the puree be
generous with the stock
you want this nice light broth basically
you can buy miso paste from Big
supermarkets and it works brilliantly
with salmon
poaching the salmon in the Miso stuff
gives it a really nice sort of sweet
earthy creamy flavor it's incredible
bring up to the ball
I'm gonna Infuse the broth and make it a
little bit more fragrant
coffee or Lime Leaf is Bay lemony inside
the Miso broth then chopped chili
Chili's in
and finely sliced Ginger
that's simmering beautifully now we're
going to post the salmon poaching means
cooking it in liquid but it's cooked
gently and the secret here is to keep
that Salmon skin on if we took the skin
off now the salmon can actually break up
whilst it's poaching
skin side down just gonna slide that in
under
nice the minute that stopping start
boiling turn it down let it simmer take
a little Ladle and just have a couple of
minutes pour over that makes sure the
top of the salmon is cooked evenly and
keeps it nice and moist
and poaching is one of the most delicate
ways of cooking so you have to handle it
with care
whilst the salmon is poaching in the
Miso broth start preparing your
vegetables I'm using tender stem
broccoli and Pak Choy
I always like to cook the leaf and the
stem separately the leaf is like sort of
spinach and the stem is so much thicker
it's almost as thick as a stick of
celery so I like to get the stems sliced
just sort of got that nice sort of
Christmas
place the leaves together nicely roll
them up nice and tight and then slice
them down
now my salmon already the flavor in that
broth has been elevated
now it tastes really fishy got the heat
chili spices the ginger and the cafe
Lime Leaf take your fish slice and place
it very gently underneath the salmon and
push it down fish slices are flexible
for that reason bend it lift it up
it's touch looking for a springy firm
texture just
sit there on top a little touch of the
broth over it
stops it from drying out
leave that to cool down for two minutes
bring the stock back up to the boil
broccoli in back Choy stems in a little
taste
it's getting better and better and
better cook the broccoli and the bok
choy stems for one minute and then add
the tops in
turn the salmon into your hand
and just peel all that skin off the skin
also helps to keep the salmon nice and
moist then gently flake the salmon
that's the secret behind
poaching everything just stays so moist
wonderful long shards of pink now just
before we serve we're going to add our
mushrooms these are enoki mushrooms you
can buy these enoki mushrooms at Big
supermarkets and good Grocers slice them
off I'm going to put half in
and the other half I'm going to serve
with the salmon toasted sesame seed oil
put a little drip in there just rub
and you're just lining almost like a
little coat of varnish start off with
your mushrooms and then my salmon
four nice layers
and then finally
the mushrooms top with the vegetables
and then finally
a nice ladle that beautiful
really Sumptuous Rich stock
lovely
and that is an amazing misu poached
salmon soup simplify your cooking by
getting organized and amazing food will
be coming out your kitchen every day and
for great food you need great
ingredients
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes one of my favorites is meatballs
and fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
Lifesaver it means you never have to
compromise on Flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off your onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs the classic way but the
exciting part is actually cook them in
coconut milk and it gives a really nice
new dimension to a sort of soft Rich
Sumptuous meatball
chop the onion nice and finely giving
those slices very close together close
to the slices the finer the onions
cut it back down at an angle slice down
just chop I want the onions nice and
fine because I want some finesse to
these meatballs The Secret of a really
good meatball is the texture getting
that balance right
between the minced beef the breadcrumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple of cloves of
garlic slice of garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in a little touch of
salt and pepper
with your mints open it up a little bit
and sort of cut it out that's salt
and pepper
for me
a good meatball is all about the the
softness the texture of that Rich beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside or
you want it nice and soft and sort of
rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then paste it back out again I've
got some really nice dried chili flakes
I'm going to season the onions with the
chili flakes chili flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
I'm gonna add some milk
[Music]
take your breadcrumbs make a little well
three four tablespoons of milk that
makes a sort of nice slightly doughy
texture but it lightens the texture of
the meatball
place that in
add your onions your garlic and your
chili in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
problem with making them too small is
the fact that they dry out quickly just
the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
getting a really nice tight squeeze that
stops IT from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavor from the onions the garlic at the
bottom look at that pan nice and hot
Touch of olive oil in there
place them
the top of your pan
nice and gently
set them in the oil
get a palette knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coriander seeds slightly spicy
and peppery just to give a really nice
flavor to the coconut milk and next some
cardamon seeds three or four onto the
board knife on
and no touch of turmeric into the center
of the pan that's going to give it a
really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier a couple of dried chilies let
them Infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of Beat It
Down that starts to release all that
lovely sort of fragrance like someone's
just let off the most amazing fragrant
air freshener in for the lemongrass
finally some fresh ginger
peel
it's nice nice and thinly
time now
turn them over
and let the other half for a wonderful
flavor
to stop
in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
and I want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of a meatball
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
that nice soft texture of the meatball
but that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth it's going to cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
and simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
touch them with your finger they should
be slightly pliable but slightly springy
gas off and finish it off with something
light and fresh zest of lime but I want
the zest
on top of the meatball
sort of cut through that richness and
then finally
squeeze fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice zesty
amazing taste
stirring the juice
[Music]
I've got that kick in that vibrant taste
now the exciting part
when you come to serve it be generous
with that coconut broth
talk the pan
get a good couple of ladles of a broth
in
meatball
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball and bringing it into the 21st
century and they're just as good cooked
from Frozen as well
[Music]